we all could use a laugh and this man is
expert at providing it whether it was
writing for Seinfeld back in the day and
producing also an executive producer and
director and writer on Curb Your
Enthusiasm he has now the EP and
co-creator of Dave on FXX combining
forces with little Dicky and he and his
brother Greg Shaffer will have a new
show Bruce brothers available for
streaming on Netflix starting next week
pleased to be calling this man my friend
for a very long time the very funny and
talented director writer producer Jeff
Schaffer on the show how you doing Jeff
I am doing great hey I have a question
for you yes because there a is there a
picture of me up or is there just some
sort of crude drawing of me with no
pants holding a lime Rickey nope
actually I would be accurate no right
now no it's a it's a photograph of you
it's an action photo of you and in what
appears to be in front of an FX X
step-and-repeat Jeff maybe it's it does
look current could be from the era of
you doing the league as well um but
that's what we've chosen for you very
handsome well I guess you can always
graphics department can always remove
the pants and add a drink that's fine
you doing all right everybody good
you're in your world I have to say yes
have you talked to anyone about the
what's gonna be arriving on your desk
not yet Jeff you may have it you have
the floor sir
this is this is stuff oh this is coming
go for it go for it breaking news
there's gonna be a new that that rich is
that a gust slab of wood or Formica I
can't remember Plexiglas
it's my new friend a an actual mug an
actual self-heating mug from Lotte Larry
[Applause] [Music]
you didn't get burned down a few were
spared and I know what everyone's asking
all of the Purell was burnt
what was the accelerant it was the
accelerant Jeff right doing accelerant
oh that was funny I got a rich I am so
excited that you were so fond of the
season that in this dark crazy time this
you had someone get a copy cup that's
been handled by countless stranger Leon
maybe just an extra for Mussina who has
Pepsi and you want to put it on your
desk next to your face in your phone you
know I'm honored I am going to spray
that down like it's the movie Silkwood
Jeff so don't worry man it will be
cleansed and disinfected by the time it
hits this desk but I had to have it it
is just such that that whole concept of
a spike store where in the world did
that come from Jeff walk me through how
you and Larry conceived of a spike store
we're trying to figure out what we want
to do for an arc and we're throwing
around ideas and Larry mentioned that
there was a place
not unless somewhere else I won't tell
you where that had treated him poorly
and it was a coffee place and god I wish
I could just rent the place next door
and drive them out of business and thus
that's how that was born where did where
did you come up with the the table the
scone the pure oh and of course then Oh
defecating we're that all come about
Jeff what we know once we knew that we
were gonna do this fight store yes we
thought oh this is a great opportunity
for us to you know have it being built
throughout the season and that gives
Larry a chance to really put his good
eye on how to improve a coffee stir
hockey track you know he's not an
inventor he's an improver so we started
to talk about all the little things that
bothered us about about you know a storm
we just thought Larry in the service
industry with how
a lot of good input you know just to
bring this full circle I heard you're
talking before yes
about the sky judge yes you understand
Larry is the world sky judge he's the
sky judge of planet Earth Larry David
exactly about about whether somebody's
doing the right thing with cell phone
etiquette or doing the right thing in
any sort of fact of life you're right
Larry is the world sky judge so it is
working out or sometimes it is a little
messy though Jeff it really is burned
down as we saw in the in the end of your
end of your season long arc Jeff
Schaffer here from curb and Dave on FXX
and soon to be on Netflix starting next
Friday bruise brothers right here on the
Rich Eisen show let's get into Dave man
how did you get hooked up with little
Dickie how did that happen Jeff and a
friend of mine said oh you got to meet
this guy you got to be a little Dicky
and I mean I knew who a little Dicky was
I mean it was a few years ago and at
that point the internet was like I don't
know 60% porn 20% clickbait and like 20%
little Dicky videos so I I was aware but
I didn't I'd never met him so we're
talking I sit down with him at scooter
Braun's place and we're talking and he
was telling me stories about his life
and they were really funny curb ask
stories there's there's a lot of Larry
David in in Dave bird and so I was like
oh that's interesting that's he's
actually a funny guy but the other thing
that really intrigued me was as he's
sitting there talking to me he's telling
me look I'm gonna be the biggest
entertainer in the history of
entertained I'm like alright well you
know
you've you've had a lot of success in
the video world I didn't you get with
that confidence is coming from but he's
like no no I was this confident before
I'd done anything before I had wrapped
in front of my girlfriend before it ever
wrapped in public I knew I was going to
be this and I just said Wow so this guy
who you know looks like a piece of
broccoli had a Bar Mitzvah is gonna be
the biggest in a care in the world he
believed I was just like wow this is
like a cartoon level delusion this is
amazing that's a really funny engine for
a show and thus dave was born on the
spot I got to tell you man
our cameo in episode 4 our phones blew
up I mean this show is taken off Jeff I
mean that that I could tell just that
alone the number of people that lit us
up on our Twitter feeds and phones
so that was a fun a fun cameo that we we
took part appreciates not a bad fantasy
team name suits on of class Wilford
Brimley's last hurrah latest fantasy
team name because we were talking about
the firm and we wondered if that was
Wilford Brimley's last hurrah being the
heavy in the firm Jeff did you put him
in Seinfeld did you put him in that post
master episode you did Brimley in that
episode just thought it would be the
funniest thing in the world to have
Wilford Brimley be the postmaster and
they were it's just that simple
sometimes you know it's funny we had we
had we had little Dicky on in 20
sixteen and he talked about how what a
die-hard fan of the Eagles he was and we
we tried to get him to write a rap for
Andy Reid called times yours cuz you
know Andy Reid would always lift off the
they'd start a press conference with the
after a game with the names of the
injured and then just turn to the media
and say time is yours
he Andy Regis would not do it we
couldn't get him to do it man
I know I know they've been totally
amazing but by the way thank you guys so
much for doing that
that camión people are really loving the
show there was a somebody just came out
yesterday that's the it's now the
second-highest comet most seen comedy on
in FX history it is uh it's doing people
are really finding it so thank you no
thank you I mean people are clearly
looking for some sort of divergence
something to make them laugh
tell me about bruised brothers Jeff what
is this you and your brother is this
based on your relationship in any way
shape or form it's gonna start streaming
on Netflix next Friday the 10th of April
what is this my brother had this idea
for a show about sort of too many
brothers who are running a craft brewery
in Van Nuys and I was like and he showed
me just sort of talking about it and it
was really really funny and I thought oh
well this is actually the next logical
progression from the lead because what's
more popular than football beer and two
brothers who've been apart for a long
time who get together and they're
they're not very good together
they're both individually they both have
a lot of issues and together it's just
worse and it's a really it's a really
really funny show and and I thought also
it's a craft brewery and you know that's
a bubble that needed to get burst I mean
every everybody in their dumb uncle is
telling you the like this IPA or that
IPA is too hoppy
and it's just I can't take it so so yes
we did the show and it's if you if you
like the league you will love this show
it is it's a new batch of really funny
young improvisers
and it's it is just good clean filthy
fun okay well and it sounds like the way
you feel about craft brewers this sounds
like you're spike brewery that you were
opening up right now on FX s is your
smite brewery has a lot of problems I
mean van nuys as you know it's known for
auto body shops and the porn industry
sex shops and between a body shop and a
sort of med men style sex shop a
high-end erotic dispensary dispensary
and it's like one of them this guy
Wilhelm his name as well but he changed
his name to actually two Vilhelm he's a
real he loves everything German and he
changed me
to vilhelm in honor of this old prussian
Duke in Germany who was responsible for
the Reinheitsgebot which was the German
purity law of like 15 34 as opposed to
the more recent German purity law of
1934 place to be the perfect hang he'll
get drunk with the customers forget to
charge them and the other brother who
put it this way when Greg first told me
about the show I was instantly
interested and not just because the
[ __ ] older brother was no much to me
fantastic Jeff Shaffer here on the Rich
Eisen show alright let's let's uh let's
finish up with some questions about
what's going on with curb and Larry all
right first of all did you have anything
to do with the the PSA that's gone
totally wildfire of Larry telling idiots
to stay at home on behalf of the state
of California helping out with the
governor's office to try and get some
people do PSA okay to get him to stay at
home and so she talked to Larry and me
and Larry was at first interested but
resisting about just putting something
out on the internet but so will we talk
it through and we were talking about
ideas and he's like all right let's try
it and so he just you know he had I
didn't get his daughter Cathy film it
and he said oh this is really funny
put it out put it out he did okay so
there's that now
what's what's going on with Season
eleven is there going to be one herb
season 11 okay so we're definitely you
know we're definitely talking about it I
got to say all your listeners know about
your side hustle that in addition to all
the other things you do yes
you're also have a side hustle as
quality control for carribean through
the air we talked about that on occasion
I don't know if I go back and forth is
it like Fight Club or not am I allowed
to talk about the fact that I'm part of
a crew that sees the show isn't in edit
paid did you check on all of it okay
right yeah no people are yeah we do talk
about that on occasion and and and it's
it's truly one of the most amazing
things that's ever happened
that's so yes I love it so anyway I
think you know Larry never wants to be
put in the position where he has to put
the show out so we usually make a have a
pretty big you know
made a lot a lot of headway before we'd
ever admit we're doing another season
right but we're I will tell you this we
are having we're having fun talking
about things mm-hmm so what is a
FaceTime session like where you just
like start where you're this is where
the the next spike store idea comes up
on a FaceTime between you and LD first
Larry's got a plug in his iPad and he we
complain about how the the outlets at
his house are neck shoulder height like
all outlets should be why does everyone
have to rummage you know like a raccoon
along the ground to plug things in a
little chatting and then yeah then we
just start throwing a doing ideas around
okay so ideas are being thrown around
for Season eleven before you have to
commit to anything I like that so that's
that we're checking that box for sure
and one one one how is the the Jets
episode now that it is aired how's that
landing is everything good Larry in the
Jets based on what happened after that
episode first of all there were so many
closeted Jets fans I had people who I've
known for a long time who never admitted
they were Jets fans yes we're like hey
I'm a Jets fan I just got to say that
was the best thing I've ever seen Wow
deep in the closet about the Jets I will
say that Larry had a a very nice chat
with with Adam GaSe okay and and I think
things are I think things are good I
mean you know when Larry was telling
people that he had a witness to his
mckagan talk about Lamar Jackson yes
with me that was me I was so when when
he talked to mechag Minh saying draft
Lamar Jackson and mechag name basically
gave him the same okay that Larry ended
its PSA with you were there for that
part of the conversation Marge
here's the thing this is what the
beautiful thing about Larry's jet fandom
as it was last summer when we when when
I saw that that episode in the Edit Bay
lights come on when the lights come on
Chris Larry and Jeff have these notes
and they ask everyone in the room these
questions yeah one of the first things
Larry said to me is like he was nervous
that the Jets would actually do well
thus making this episode that airs in
January totally out of place right
remember that Jeff you had that question
I told him I hear you that he was such a
fan like me it's levian bells coming all
that stuff and then week 2 hits when the
mononucleosis happens and I texted you
guys saying you're fine
that episodes gonna be just great in
January and then the episode airs
you added a mononucleosis scene did you
not to that yeah we knew we were gonna
leave a little slot open we did a
reshoot late late because we wanted to
capture whatever whatever was going on
in that in that somber sad so far it is
the Jets we wanted to make sure we
caught some this again you barely put in
something about mono who gets mono like
you're a high school girl on the swim
team and I loved it so you isn't that
amazing you left a little spot for the
inevitable jets trapdoor opening for her
for a little bit of an it add-on man
you're the best Jeff thanks for the call
appreciate it
let's stay in touch man you were your
your your new show Dave is on fire
Wednesday's 10:00 Eastern on FXX you
could just check it out the next day on
Hulu the streaming is through the roof
curb season 10 was amazing love to hear
that season 11 is potentially already
getting some of the designs placed in
Bruce brothers gonna debut on Netflix
Friday April 10th look forward to that
you take care of yourself thank you
brother
that's very good suggestion
I knew he had something to do with that
PSA 1 take 1 take Larry okay by the way
all right
he was given I don't know if I was gonna
say anything but the self-heating bugs
on the way wow they're going to have a
latte Larry mug right here on the Rich
Eisen show set that automatically
top-five knick-knack that we had it's
pretty great the humid sky judge
everybody I mean he is alright